attenzione questo gioco a colori flash
anti mori che fanno casino va beh questo
lo sapevo bene attenti ragazzi benvenuti
questo video sono fi dj oggi siamo
tornati su export burt non solo
ricordate sarebbe loro dei simpson
volevo fare un altro episodio perché c'è
uno nelle mappe che avevo provato e tra
l'altro mi sa che questo forse non era
proprio uscito il capitolo 3
vorrei provare a fare il capitolo 3d ex
forward è veramente pesante se nessuno
ha visto e l'altro video di barbato
doveva vedere
lecco new game commissario winchester
ecco questo non è esattamente family
friendly ma chi se ne frega a me non gli
hanno investito celim 1 questo
commissario è successo
mazza che panza è proprio lui e
winchester
che bello attraverso è tutto fuorché all
export mark shurtleff link che bello non
riescono i capitolini sorbara tu sei una
persona meno contenta del mondo in
realtà perché i fatti li prendo io a io
sono winchester non hanno capito e sta
roba qua allora il successo questo c'è
flanders c'è marge bart lisa tutti i
mori al report evidenzia a devo prendere
tanta storia per riportare il fatto che
sono soggetti quindi io devo indagare su
cosa è successo mi ha dato un nuovo fare
questa cosa c'è anche omer che è morto
più pila però perfetto siamo a due
cos'è sta roba mio dio posso anche
sbirciare sotto le macchine perché
scelta sopra guarda di sapere comunque
fantastico non avevo assolutamente
provato questa roba ma chi è stato a io
devo scoprire chi è stato la vediamo chi
è che non c'è ci sono tutti c'è anche
maggie quindi chi può essere stato a
fare questo lavoro
secondo me krusty il clown
quindi io devo arrivare solo devo
arrivare a prendere sei uova adesso ne
ho tre
ecco adesso anche un infarto permesso
buongiorno sono il commissario
winchester porca vacca che avevo ma la
smetti così che succeda forse devo
rimanere sul tragitto sono mi fa uscire
può essere lo rimane sul tragitto e
rimaniamo sul tragitto familiare porte
evidence che i quattro siamo a 5 non ho
neanche ben capito che cosa sto facendo
ma va bene manca uno ragazzi che non ho
mai capito o permesso mamma mia quanto
horror non mi saltate in faccia vi prego
vi supplico almeno quello mi rimane un
nuovo da trovarci e non è un nuovo in
realtà ma un'evidenza però mi rimane
eccola qua se porca vacca
qualcuno mi spiega aiuto tipo temporaneo
cos'è ma perché è perché c'è un homer
impazzito che mi segue aiuto ma basta
che fastidio mi chiude il frigo non sto
capendo solo perché sa qual è il senso
anche un po ridere tra l'altro questa
buffa hanno dovuto fare le uova
smettiamo di far casino basta
marianna fattori possono attraverso
sostituiscono maya ma impossibile per
una specie di temporale ragazze non ho
ben capito sto facendo aiuto homer basta
è veramente velocissimo ci sono solo se
ce l'ho fatta bene
yes e quindi era solo questo livello a
noa ecco questa è la tutorial salve
signor homer cit menu lpr più vi piace
sai che sta succedendo ragazzi stanno
succedendo cose psichedeliche
non sto capendo ve lo giuro
ma eccoci una seconda parte sono morto
sono caduto giù mi ha spinto homer va
bene sono morte quindi sono nell'aldilà
è giusto allora quella teoricamente
dovrebbe essere marge io devo trovare 6
uova
se prostata sono nascoste in casa questa
era esattamente come il primo episodio
quindi devo riuscire a trovare le uova
senza che marge mi hanno però sono del
commissario vincesse il secondo ancora
non l'ho capito cosa c'entra notata una
maledizione
ecco posto magari non so dove possa mai
essere marginone ideato veloce tu vuoi
22 ancora sempre due scalzone che sono
fondati 2 ma pasta o 3 edizione di
andare al piano di sopra teoricamente
loro margine su dove non ho capito
allora piano di sopra teoricamente
secondo scola casa di simpson dovrebbe
essere qua infatti c'è spero che non ci
sia qualcun altro oltre mar ci sono un
casino quattro sì 281 dai se riesco al
primo tentativo sono un fenomeno è come
l'ho detto ma perché vedo attraverso i
muri sta cosa molto strana annusato uno
stile veramente strano per fare questo
guai per fare il seguito che mi dice al
sesto non c'è mannaia
[Applauso]
sono stato 2 mar o qualcosa all'inizio
sono stato due ore e cercarlo non
c'erano dai 0 su 6 dai ce la posso fare
è difficilissimo cup e nascosto tra
strabene che c'è anche qua tipo hanno
visto non è che al di fuori quando mi
puoi prendere credo
e per questo che amo i videogiochi ora
ragazzi forse l'ho pagata potrebbe
essere vero
[Applauso]
scherzavo poi un tasso devi schiacciare
85 volte perché è proprio cercare capito
c'è l'ansia fatta gioco ma visto proprio
lui 22 sempre 23 perfetto c'è anche il
corridoio principale sai che non ho
visto prova ad evitare di andarci corico
ai cuori 4 regalami un 5 0 ma yahoo la
frase non ha mai avuto effetto manco
quando la dicevo ai prof
devi trovarne 2 dai non è impossibile ma
poi c'e roma è entrato fosse molto
d'aiuto 5 tv 67 66 league di house per
uscire aiuto fuorigioco riso forse da
forse ce l'ho fatta addirittura saio
macori
ce l'ho fatta e stato bravissimo
schivato anche omer alla fine che non
era scontato è perché era difficile 12
su 24 quanto tu e la sua parte dopo un
concerto di skrillex cos'è sta roba
ma quante psichedelica st parte raga
allora siamo sempre siamo sempre
nell'aldilà a ecco non devo cadere ma si
può proprio cadere su cadere giù ma
aiuto ma era un bug magrone alla ragazzi
se se non posso cadere pio la macchina a
ecco si creava la la strada devono
farmela a piedi
pensate irlan qui l'obiettivo è tra le
uova in giro qua senza che homer mi
prenda
ma non dovrebbe essere troppo difficile
prova sotto tono e trovare le uomo che
costeggia ne stava un'acqua ce ne
stavano anche dall'altra parte perfetto
12 così con questa siamo a 3 occhio che
deve d'una l'iphone dissi mo tipo ma
proprio in fondo in fondo di tirare
dritto esatto ragazzino è già ecco
perfetto stavo dicendo dei giochi dove
mi devo guidare non è che sono proprio
il massimo ogni volta che prendo un
nuovo tra l'altro si sente o perché ok
dice la parola mar
non si capisce perché visto che tanto
non sono neanche io homer quindi boh nel
primo video gli pare che ho fatto tutto
ciò che mi pare fosse over non so sicuro
ma i paesi ogni volta che prendo un
nuovo aumenta la velocità il palmo anaya
c'era un muro
mamma mia che si è posta di bucio de
qualcosa
mamma mia ragazzi mi è andata benissimo
mi è andata benissimo sto da ora dovrei
fare il giro di beccare parcheggio che
qua però per prenderla nel perché ci
devo fare veramente un magheggio fa
anche rima ci prova
mamma mia dai dai dai tanti altri
delegati non ci credo
nato ho fatto un rating che fa ho vinto
veramente
ecco mi sembrava ragazzi ho fatto una
tritata che vi giuro che anche in diesel
in fast and furious
devo capire che mi sta portando in casa
mi ha riportato in casa dove loro hanno
incontrato la prima volta fantastico
ragazzi che sarà ex formart spero vi sia
piaciuto per me è bellissimo ogni volta
anche se un po difficile il finale come
sempre però merita merito un sacco
quindi spero vi sia piaciuto cosa che mi
sono seduto mi piace anche al riso al
comando da iniziare serio se rischiate
vera ci vediamo da flanders nei
proseguito belle ragazze
[Musica]